My Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
but very good guy too.
Very good fighter in him and Vinnie were both in the UFC so they got a lot of
good
press it up and then they also got uh,
uh,
my boy jake shields.
That's a good fine.
That is the same night as the UFC fight in I think as the same night as UFC
fight in New York City fucked up world series.
That's a,
that's a tough draw for them to.
Everyone fucked up.
Yo.
Let's,
let's get busy with this.
What do you think about this Brendan Shop?
I am very excited about this fight.
I think people are fucking sleeping on Eddie Alvarez.
I think he's a dangerous dangerous 155 pounder that motherfucker can punch.
He punches hard,
he's fast as fuck and it does not a human alive that's more gained in that kit.
I agree 100 percent.
If you've never seen him fight before,
you got to watch his fights in bellator with Michael Chandler and dream.
That's just fights him.
Dream to Michael Chandler is another dude who's out there who is world class.
That could easily be fighting and winning in the UFC.
Oh yeah,
and you see it now with Eddie Alvarez because it took a while for Eddie to get
comfortable in the UFC.
He Donald worked him over and his first fight because dismantled by John,
but now he's training with your book mchenry and Connor's a goddamn phenom and
he's a.
he's got as for us a hobby likes to call it the touch of death in his hands.
That's a scary fight,
man.
Anyone who thinks it's an easy flight or not,
a big fight for conor is they just don't know the sport out of their time on the
underground king,
I think at 55 and everyone knows I'm the biggest con or nut writer in the world
at 55.
I just don't see a ton of success there.
I think Eddie Alvarez,
if you look at the top five,
we've talked about this for you,
like the top five.
It's his easiest matchup and that's a fucking nightmare for them because it can
grapple his ass off.
He's been so many big fights.
It doesn't get tired.
He doesn't mind winning by decision.
He doesn't get tired and he's a bigger grandpa.
Yeah.
Those are two and he can't fucking crack and look at his resume.
Resume.
Chris.
He's crisp,
striking.
He's not an easy guy to hit.
You know you can hit him and he gets rocked and he survives.
If you watch his chandler fights,
Eddie Alvarez got rocked and survived against Chandler and a couple other guys
over in Bella.
Well,
think about how.
How's Connor win this fight?
You go through a hassle.
Knock him out.
He has five rounds of document.
You're not winning decision against that.
He could win a decision.
I don't think so.
I disagree.
Why do you worry about the fight with Gilbert Melendez?
Eddie wanted decision.
The Gilbert Melendez,
fine.
Oh No,
I'm saying Edwin's by decision,
but we don't think that connor could beat him in a similar fight.
No,
no.
You don't have the endurance.
The takedowns.
The grappling with the striking.
As the rounds go on,
the knockout power goes down.
Do you think people sleep on Alvarez wrestling because I think they forget.
I forget how good of a restaurant is and his endurance,
but yeah,
it's a scary.
Where did he wrestle?
He was a high level guy.
Division One.
Oh yeah.
All American.
I'm not sure.
But uh,
compared to connor.
He's fucking Dan.
Yo.
This fight.
This fight is nasty,
right?
We all know that those guys were talking about Jimmy man who's about to go down
and.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying this phrase nasty.
Just not confuse people at home,
but I,
I agree with you man.
I think people sleep on them.
It's too.
You've rolled with like a real division one wrestler and you realized how
fucking strong the wrestling is.
All American.
That's high school.
National Prep.
All American.
What is,
what is this college wrestling record?
He doesn't have one.
You.
No college wrestling doesn't say as college wrestling.
And he got his wrestling and fricking dream.
How about that?
He bypassed that career and went right into mma.
So he was a high level high school wrestling,
which is not as impressive as a college wrestler,
but when you see him wrestle,
you know he's got some skills like to stand up though.
He loves trade,
just wants to stand up.
Obviously.
It's too smart.
He's been in some of the best,
you know.
So Connor's down in an easy to take down though to highschool champ.
Chad Mendez begs to differ.
I mean as time goes on,
he's going to be harder and harder to get that Chad Mendez fight though in
Connor's defense,
he had a pretty fucked up knee in that fight he was getting.
He was getting stem cell injections in his knee,
but that's also the only rest where we've ever seen conor fight taking down
pretty effortlessly.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's the only thing we can go off and say,
I got a bad knee.
I get that.
It's tough fight,
man.
Because people think Karen's gonna lock those guys.
They don't know the sport man.
I saw the fire went,
oh fuck.
It's true.
But also I could see connor just is gonna win.
He's gonna if,
if Connor wins,
he's going to Mirko.
Connor has some vicious fucking power in his hands.
Has Eddie been knocked out?
He's been stopped.
Chandler stopped him.
He rear naked choke him and beat him for the title.
I'm knocked out.
I don't think he's been knocked out.
He's been doing some dog fights.
He's just his game as they come.
I think he's one of those guys that fight at its very best when he's scared.
Correct.
I think that's going to be one of the best things about this fight is that he
thinks conor is a dangerous motherfucker.
Just like he thought how failed on Joe's.
He stopped those signed just in the first round and a lot of people,
including me,
were making the argument that Dos Anjos,
if you look at the guys he's beaten,
stopped cowboy in the first round,
beat the shit out of Nate Diaz,
had us beat pettis up,
stopped Ben Henderson,
crushed him.
I mean,
you look at all the guys that he's beaten.
There's a real argument that he's one of the best lightweight of all time and
then Eddie went and stopped him in the first round so everyone thought he was
gonna get murdered.
Like you went,
thought Eddie was just.
You can get.
It was huge.
He doesn't have the marquee name recognition type thing.
They don't know him yet.
Dangerous fight for conor man,
because he has such a big name.
But yeah.
What if,
if connor does,
when you imagine the 55 belt holder is crazy and then I think you'll forget
about Tony and Tony.
Well,
no,
we're not forgetting about them for sure,
but I think the thing about Eddie Alvarez is that he has the title and that's
why it's sellable is it was just conor mcgregor versus Eddie Alvarez and they
didn't have the title.
You can't sell it.
It's just that the Miller garden though,
middle so valuable.
We realize how valuable that title,
because Tony is right in there,
in my opinion,
as is Barboza as as a couple of guys,
Habib number go.
Madoff is of course everybody's first choice.
She's undefeated.
Nobody's been able to deal with that crap.
Suplex your face,
nasty fucking striker to
give him a.
he's fighting.
He's fighting Michael Johnson and the next ride in that car.
That's a fucking great fight.
Johnson,
just coming off of the knockout.
A poor ea.
That's a great fight.
Great fight on the main card.
Let's be real.
We always argue what's the best UFC fight card?
That's the best UFC fight card of Baltimore.
Even close.
It's like by foot holds up.
Yeah.
If it holds up towards the lineup,
the lineup is insane.
You have three world title fights.
You have our versus conor Mcgregor.
You have tyron Woodley's fighting wonderboy.
Funny People forget that.
This steven happening because everybody's talking about other fights.
They forget this fight.
How about Yoni and Jay?
Check versus Carolina Cable Kovich.
Come on,
man.
Nobody's even talking about that and then you have Chris.
Why Med versus yellow?
Motherfucking Ramiro.
Come on
then our boy.
Cowboy counseling versus Calvin
and look at.
This is Raquel Pennington that fights never met.
Raquel Pennington is one of the best Bantam weight in the world.
Nobody talks about her because she's.
She's won some fights in a crazy way,
like the Ashley Evan Smith fight with just had some great,
but she looks.
You took holly home to a fucking split decision I had.
The girls have lost a lot though in to eight and six.
They have brawls,
Bro.
These girls go after it and Pennington and in my opinion is super,
super aggressive.
I like watching her fight me.
She got beat up in the last fight.
She did.
God Amanda Nunez Nunez?
No.
Oh my God.
Frankie Edgar versus sharpie Stevens.
Fucking.
I almost forgot about that.
That's insane.
Not neuroma.
Johnson.
Holy Shit.
It's not even close.
There's not even a second place.
Holy Shot.
Ticketed entity.
Oh my God.
To my favorites.
Holding decided to go gangbusters on this.
Halfway on the towel is fighting.
Tim Timbo a fun fight and that's all fun.
Fight trains in New York with Henzel.
Jim Miller and she'll go.
I was fighting 1:55.
This one was first fight.
I call that the throat throwback.
Thursday five.
Have you seen what Alvarez looks like?
It's crazy.
I have not.
He's reading,
he's way thinner and he's lighter.
You know,
you remember when Elvis fought Matt Hughes when he didn't make weight?
Yeah,
and he was a coal rilla.
Just go eat.
The baby girl is so jacked.
It was hair said.
See Ya.
He had.
He had muscles that would start above his and may
look like a pit bull.
Well,
excuse me,
sir.
You're actually turn into a pit bull.